aleppo's children are being buried by
the bombs child after child is being
entombed in the rubble there are huge
cheers when they're pulled out alive but
what life are they emerging into
[Music]
astonishingly four-year-old rawan is
still alive our camera crew filmed her
remarkable rescue about three weeks ago
she was the only survivor in her
immediate family the three sisters have
brought their mother and father all died
a few days after her rescue rwan is pale
and terribly weak she's horribly
traumatized by her experience but
remarkably physically okay her
grandmother is now her carer and she's
overwhelmed with grief and worry free
weeks later rwan is looking much
stronger but she's missing her family
and the prospects for her life is tough
for everyone in Aleppo but especially so
if you're a child trapped inside a city
under fire the priority is doing what's
needed to get a meal even if it means
working on a rubbish tip gathering
materials to make fuel
I'm nauseous lee bumsoo heard you over
haven't an assassin I would if I were
him at any time and by the way William
now you're back behind our banner
hanna-barbera not hire a lot better but
you've won what once was stolen
miserable self ba ba ba da da ba dee da
ba Jie and I'm the master worst of all
and the man me animal ambassador mr.
balloon yeah man I'm for almond how
oilmen can she she's in but work and
play can be lethal when you're a child
in Aleppo City right now a cluster bomb
ripped off comers leg who's being helped
by his brother but another brother was
killed by the same cluster bomb here
there's not a lot of sympathy
jános fiala me handle my fear she
reassured methine Sam sir I dropped out
here and all too often children are
losing their parents there's nothing
more dangerous than having a father
who's a volunteer for the white helmets
their father Amma drives a digger for
the white helmets shoveling through the
rubble trying to free those trapped
underneath with the constant risk of
being hit by secondary bombs in history
an observable volatile zhihui element in
a terrible mcafee in the a busy bar
Emiliana for been a absolute you had
Jehovah the Minotaur ahah ahah ahah ahah
the data landfall MFE were defended in
the story and four daughters like magum
if you're in Aleppo City there's a high
chance your father won't survive your
childhood
Alex Crawford sky news on the
turkish-syrian border